"New year, new me."
It's a phrase pretty much everyone says as
they approach the end of one year and the
beginning of another.
Turns out, it's a phrase the folks at Netflix
must have been uttering as they put together
their line-up for January 2020.
Beginning January 2020, Netflix subscribers
can sink their teeth into four stellar action
flicks - and let it suffice to say: It's all
killer, no filler.
Thrill ride, anyone?
Based on the Marvel Comics character, Ghost
Rider stars Nicolas Cage as the titular superhero
- and rest assured, he's not your average
motorcycle stuntman turned fiery avenger on
wheels.
That's coming your way on January 1st.
"Time to clear the air."
"Heh heh haha."
Meanwhile, both installments of Quentin Tarantino's
epic Kill Bill films will be ready for your
viewing pleasure on January 1st.
In a career-defining performance, Uma Thurman
plays Beatrix Kiddo, an ex-assassin obsessively
hunting down her former lover - the mysterious
Bill.
Meanwhile, she exacts her revenge on all the
men and women who have betrayed her over the
years.
And beginning on January 31st, you can check
out the 2017 action-thriller American Assassin,
starring Dylan O'Brien as a man hellbent on
avenging the death of his fiancée after she's
murdered by terrorists.
Are you a big fan of fantasy films?
You're officially in luck: Netflix will be
bringing plenty of magic into our lives - and
soon.
On January 1st, Guillermo del Toro's sprawling,
Oscar-winning dark fantasy Pan's Labyrinth
hits the streaming service.
The story involves a young girl who discovers
a mythical world of which she is the ruler.
"No No!"
Oh, and you'll definitely want to check out
the second and third movies in Peter Jackson's
Lord of the Rings trilogy: The Two Towers
and The Return of the King will both be available
for streaming beginning on January 1st.
Here's a New Year's resolution for you: Don't
let a drama-free day go by in January 2020.
There are loads of acclaimed dramas coming
to Netflix - including Catch Me If You Can
starring Leonardo DiCaprio.
He plays a brilliant con artist and bank robber
on the run from an FBI agent, played by Tom
Hanks.
The film is a total delight, particularly
if you're into all sorts of wily cat-and-mouse
shenanigans.
"My name is Frank Taylor, I'm a co-pilot for
PAN-AM.
I'd like to cash this check here and then
I'd like to take you out for a steak dinner."
Let the games begin on January 1st.
Another Leonardo DiCaprio film is coming to
Netflix that same day - and it's quite the
mind-melter.
Inception involves a burglar who can creep
into people's dreams and pluck out all their
secrets.
Prepare to have your brain scrambled by this
beguiling, endlessly entertaining film.
There's even more gripping goodness coming
your way on January 1st, including the whip-smart
comedy-drama Up in the Air, starring George
Clooney and Anna Kendrick.
On January 18th, The Bling Ring starts streaming.
Based on a true story, this stylish drama
involves a group of crafty teenagers who figure
out how to rob the luxurious homes of celebrities.
In the mood for something completely different?
We Are Your Friends starts streaming on January
27th, and it's a music drama that just so
happens to be directed by Max Joseph of Catfish
fame.
Get ready to laugh, because Netflix is bringing
plenty of classic comedies to the streamer
in January 2020.
First up is Ferris Bueller's Day Off, an iconic
comedy about cutting school in favor of all
sorts of mischievous highjinx.
That will be available to stream on January
1st.
That's also the day you can check out the
classic 1971 musical comedy Willy Wonka & the
Chocolate Factory.
"Boy what a great series this would have been!"
"Wonka!"
"This is kinda strange."
"Yes, strange Charlie, but it's fun - haha!"
And if that's not quite enough whimsy for
you, Tim Burton's 2005 update, Charlie and
the Chocolate Factory, also begins streaming
on January 1st.
That's not all.
Hitch starring Will Smith is coming to Netflix
on January 1st, along with the zany romp Yes
Man, starring Jim Carrey.
Then, on January 15th, Netflix starts streaming
the cutesy 2002 teen comedy Big Fat Liar.
Sure, why not?
There's only one stand-up comedy special coming
to Netflix in January 2020, but it's one that
you absolutely should not miss.
Comedian Fortune Feimster brings her first-ever
Netflix comedy special to the streamer on
January 21st.
In Fortune Feimster: Sweet & Salty, the Office
Christmas Party star reminisces about her
childhood, including her experiences as a
Girl Scout.
She also opens up about her family's absurd
relationship with a certain chicken wing restaurant
chain, and reveals how one film helped her
come to terms with her sexuality.
Scared?
Perhaps you should be.
Netflix is adding tons of amazing horror films
and thrillers to the streaming service in
January 2020.
On January 1st, you can watch The Ring, a
supernatural thriller about a cursed videotape
that kills anyone who watches it within seven
days.
That same day, you can check out The Talented
Mr. Ripley, a twisted thriller starring Matt
Damon as a charming con artist and serial
killer.
Finally, What Lies Beneath is a supernatural
tale starring Harrison Ford and Michelle Pfeiffer
as a well-to-do couple living in a haunted
house.
Expect plenty of twists and turns in that
one.
Then, on January 30th, Briam De Palma's Raising
Cain hits Netflix.
This underrated gem stars John Lithgow as
Dr. Carter Nix, a brilliant child psychologist
suffering from multiple personality disorder.
Following a shocking discovery, one of those
personalities - the titular Cain - comes to
the fore and Carter's actions grow increasingly
violent.
This is some trashy, twisted fun that's chockablock
with unforgettables performances - all of
which come from Lithgow.
A handful of Netflix originals are presenting
their final seasons, including Anne with an
E on January 3rd and The Ranch on January
24th.
Other shows will be continuing their highly
successful runs.
Keep an eye out for the sixth season of the
comedy series Grace and Frankie on January
15th.
Then there's the second season of the runaway
hit Sex Education on January 17th.
Meanwhile, the spellbinding third season of
Chilling Adventures of Sabrina is coming for
you on January 24th, and the second season
of the documentary series I AM A KILLER starts
streaming on January 31st.
Of course, we'd be remiss not to mention what's
arguably the best TV offering on Netflix:
The sixth and final season of BoJack Horseman
arrives on the last day of January, and you
definitely won't want to miss that.
"Today sucks.
The story of my life is that I never get anything
nice."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.